[Music]
the goat scene tomorrow is quite the day
today I'm here with Buster the goat he's
a six-year-old Nubian and we're on the
set today of xmus Buster has been doing
film work I want to say he started when
he was about 4 months old was his first
set he's very smart goat and he can be a
bit of a troublemaker which is what
he'll be doing on the set today I've
never worked with baby goats before no I
can say that confidently goats are
perfect little an animal to have around
I've worked with dogs a lot but no goats
they're going to be very professional
and I think they're going to be fun and
really down to earth and we've all seen
the goat videos how can somebody not
like a
goat goats are
great